-President Biden and Senate
Democrats say
they'll move quickly to
appoint and confirm a successor
to retiring Supreme
Court Justice Stephen Breyer,
which they absolutely must
because if Republicans
had their way,
they'd almost certainly
keep the seat vacant
until they could
fill it themselves.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it is not often
I get to report good news
on this show,
but things are finally
looking up for Democrats
because they'll have a chance
to choose a new
Supreme Court justice.
After 27 years
on the Supreme Court today,
we learned that
Justice Stephen Breyer,
who's 83 years old,
is retiring.
Justice Breyer is one of the
three remaining liberal justices
in the six-three court.
-I was proud and grateful
to be there at the start
of his distinguished career
in the Supreme Court,
and I'm very proud
to be here today
on his announcement
of his retirement.
-The overall, sort of,
ideological split on the court
will not change one iota.
It is a, generally speaking,
a six-to-three conservative
majority court.
-That's right, everyone,
liberals get to maintain
a three-six minority. Whoo!
Round of tap waters
for everyone!
Who wants tap?
We got tap from the sink.
Wally, breakout an appropriate
number of balloons.
Okay. You know what?
You know what,
I think we can go ahead
and drop a single "confettum."
Try to keep an eye on it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We also called up DJ Khaled
and asked if we could borrow
his celebratory air horn.
And he asked what for,
and I explained the good news
about maintaining a three to six
minority on the court.
And then he told me
that I played myself.
And I said, "Can I have
the air horn or not?"
He said, "You can have a horn
appropriate to the news,
so this is what we got."
-[ Horn blares ]
-Free horn!
Who played whose self now?
That being said, this will
still be a historic appointment
because today Biden reaffirmed
his commitment
to putting the first
Black woman on the court,
which is obviously a momentous
and long overdue step,
but otherwise Biden
has been pretty tight-lipped
about his choice.
Yesterday, for example,
he demurred when asked about it
by reporters
at a White House event
and jokingly asked someone
on a panel with him
if they wanted to join
the Supreme Court.
-There has been no announcement
from Justice Breyer.
Let him make whatever statement
he's going to make,
and I'll be happy
to talk about it later.
-We're going to start
by asking Tom --
Tom Linebarger -- to --
to offer your thoughts.
Please, sir.
-Thank you, Mr. President.
It's an honor to be here.
-Want to go to the
Supreme Court, Tom?
-I'm just going to demure
on that one.
-Hey, man, don't joke around
like that,
because that's absolutely
how Trump picked Kavanaugh.
[As Trump]
We need a Supreme Court justice.
Hey, you.
You, with the beer bong.
You want to be
on the Supreme Court?
[As Kavanaugh]
Who, me or my buddy Squee?!
[Normal voice]
And I'm just joking.
He wasn't chosen randomly.
Trump was given a list
by The Federalist Society,
which is a shadowy
group of conservatives
who secretly control the levers
of power in this country
when Republicans are in office.
You know what, Wally?
Get rid of that one balloon.
[ Air screeches out of balloon ]
[ Laughter ]
Did you strangle it?
And then today, Biden appeared
at the White House
alongside Breyer to officially
announce Breyer's retirement
but made clear to reporters
he would not take questions.
-I'm not going to take
any questions
because I think
it's inappropriate
to take questions
with the Justice here.
He's still sitting
on the bench,
but you'll have plenty
of opportunities
to get me later today
and for the rest of the week,
next week, too.
So thank you very much.
Thank you.
[ Reporters shouting questions ]
-And thank goodness this time
President Biden made sure
to walk away from the microphone
because we all know
what happens when he doesn't.
Here, though. Here --
Here's my question about that.
Did he really think
no one would hear him?
I mean, even if the mic
wasn't there,
you're still in a room
full of people.
You're surrounded by report--
You're on camera!
Even if Biden just
mouthed the words,
I'm pretty sure
we could've read his lips.
Like, watch my mouth.
I think you can tell what I just
said. Even without the words,
his expression says,
"You stupid son of a bitch."
[ Laughter ]
Forget the hot mic,
Biden's got a hot face.
So before today's
official announcement,
Biden and his aides
were walking on eggshells
and trying to be
respectful of Breyer
because in our dumb system,
there was nothing
stopping Breyer
from just changing his mind
and sticking around.
And we all have to just nod
and pretend
that having a forever job
this important
isn't totally [bleep] crazy.
I mean, what about
an employee review every decade?
Is that too much to ask?
Whoever came up with the idea
of lifetime appointments
must have been a --
-Stupid son of a bitch.
-But regardless of Biden
playing coy,
he and Senate Democrats
have made clear
that they plan to move fast
to confirm Breyer's successor.
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
said the Senate would move with
"all deliberate speed."
Although forgive me
if I don't trust
Senate Democrats
to move quickly.
No one who wears
their glasses like this
is known for their urgency.
In ophthalmology,
they call that glasses position
the "hold your horses."
[ Laughter ]
Schumer looks like he's sampling
every flavor at a Baskin-Robbins
before ordering.
[As Schumer] And now let me try
a little of the Rocky Road.
This is getting harder,
not easier.
I hope the people behind me
haven't been waiting too long.
Oh, dear!
[Normal voice]
Still, Democrats --
Still, Democrats
seem aware of the urgency
and the need to move quickly
because Republicans
have repeatedly implied
or said outright
that if they had their way,
they would hold the seat hostage
and keep it empty
until a Republican can fill it.
That's their position now
and was their position in 2016,
when Republicans, including
Ted Cruz and Donald Trump,
infamously said they would never
confirm a Democratic nominee,
no matter what year it was.
-You've said that the president
shouldn't nominate anyone
in the rest of his term
to replace Justice Scalia.
-I think it's up
to Mitch McConnell
and everybody else to stop it.
It's called delay, delay, delay.
-Sounds like the one guy
at a soccer match
who doesn't quite know
how to do the chant.
"Olé, olé, olé, oh --
-Delay delay.
[ Laughter ]
That was in 2016,
but it won't surprise you to
learn that nothing has changed.
Mitch McConnell has already said
he likely wouldn't confirm
a Biden nominee in 2024,
if Republicans win
back the Senate,
and left the door open
to stonewalling a nominee
in 2023, as well, saying,
"Cross those bridges
when I get there,
we're focusing on '22."
I don't rule anything in or out
about how to handle nominations
if I'm in the majority position.
You can't even
bring yourself to say
that you'd consider
a president's Supreme Court pick
in a non-election year.
So what's your position then?
Only Republicans
are allowed to govern?
Oh, that is their position?
[ Laughter ]
But then that wouldn't be
a democracy, right?
Well, what would it be?
Oh, well, that's not good.
If McConnell got his way,
Biden's only job
would be grilling hot dogs,
eating ice cream,
and giving people finger guns
at the State of the Union.
And that right there -- that
right there is the difference
between being vice president
and being president.
Vice president, it's like riding
shotgun on a road trip,
just messing with the radio,
winking at the girls
in other cars,
doing that hand thing
with the wind.
But now that he's the one
driving, he's all,
"Everybody shut up!
I'm trying to concentrate!
Can I get over there?!
Our exit's coming up!"
Several GOP senators went
even further than McConnell,
telling CNN they would oppose
any Biden nominee,
no matter what year it is.
Iowa senator Chuck Grassley,
the ranking Republican
on the Judiciary Committee,
even went so far as to make up
another totally
nonexistent rule, telling CNN...
First of all, don't tell us
to go back to 1886
just because
you go back to 1886.
I'm not saying Grassley's old,
but his first campaign
was for president of Pangaea.
"Only I can keep us together!"
Second, there's no such rule.
As CNN noted...
Do you think we can't
just look this stuff up,
or have you just not heard
about Google
and think we have to go
to the library to find it?
"Have fun going through
microfiche, ya losers!"
And that's not a joke
about Chuck Grassley
being too old
to know about Google.
That's a joke about Grassley
being bad at technology,
like the time
he tweeted out of nowhere
with no additional context...
[ Laughter ]
I'm so relieved
we found that tweet.
One of our interns spent all day
looking through the stacks
at the Twitter Library
in Long Island City.
They found that
and the deer carcass.
So clearly these guys
just make [bleep] up as they go.
You know, the same way
your mom does
which she has too much gin
during a game of Monopoly.
"Mom, you can't put a hotel
on a railroad!"
[Slurring] "Well, where are
the people supposed to stay?
You know, while they wait
for their train.
I'll bet there's a nice bar
in that little hotel."
"You have a problem, Mother!"
"Well, that, I better call
Dr. Hendrick's."
There's no reason
to ever take seriously
anything these guys say
ever again.
They blocked President Obama's
Supreme Court nominee
eight months before an election
and then rushed to confirm
Amy Coney Barrett
eight days before an election.
Now they're saying, even when
it's not an election year,
they won't confirm
a Democratic nominee.
Next, McConnell is going to
claim the Constitution says...
This is why Breyer
had to retire now --
so Democrats could replace him
before Republicans potentially
win back the Senate in November.
And to help nudge Breyer
toward retirement,
there's been a sustained
pressure campaign
from progressives.
-It is clear
that the court's future
is really his main reason
for leaving
after almost three decades
on the court.
He has spoken extensively,
particularly over the past year.
He even wrote a book
that was released
in September.
And in those speeches,
in his book,
he expressed concern
that the public views
the court as political
and he talks about
how that perception
could really erode faith
in the court.
He understands this relentless,
over the past year,
progressive pressure on him
to step down.
In fact, the progressive group
Demand Justice just last spring,
they paraded a mobile billboard
past the Supreme Court
with the simple words
"Breyer, retire,"
trying to get
their message out there.
-I have to say I enjoy the idea
of paying
for a mobile billboard
that targets one guy.
It's like seeing an ad on
the side of a bus that says...
Also, can we please dispense
with this ridiculous fiction
that the court somehow
isn't political?
That's all it is.
They want all of us to act
like it's the Jedi Council
soberly deliberating over
what's best for the galaxy
when it's really just a group
of Republicans and Democrats
nominated by Republicans
and Democrats who do the things
Republicans and Democrats
want them to do.
Pretending the court
isn't political
is like pretending
reality-show casts are assembled
for the purposes of
having drama-free interactions.
"I don't know
where we went wrong
with this season
of 'Real Housewives,'
but some of these ladies
do not get along!"
This is an opportunity
for Biden and Democrats
to make a historic impact
on the court
by confirming the first
Black woman in U.S. history,
a move that is both momentous
and long overdue.
But it says a lot
about our current politics
that if Breyer hadn't retired
now, there's a good chance
Republicans would have held
the seat hostage
and never let Biden
nominate anyone,
which, if you ask me,
is pretty...
-Stupid.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over two million
meals a year to men, women,
and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.